you have so many good ideas a lot of
good damn ideas are you kidding me i
want to ask him
uh you look like you got mad at me i
complimented you and you kind of got mad
like i got a lot of damn good ideas
thomas the audacity of you the audacity
to even question my ideas how about a
store that sells loose stuff
all loose nothing in packages all loose
stuff what do you mean loose stuff like
like for example why do you need a store
describe what you're saying that sounds
like a
how many times how many times have you
used a band-aid right you bought a whole
box
right right use one band-aid right then
it took three or four
years before you cut yourself again
so you're wait a minute you're saying a
store where you go in and you buy one
band-aid
loose stuff one band-aid you need a
band-aid
five dollars that's what i'm saying see
wait so it's gonna be more expensive
there's always more money the less you
buy the more money it is five dollars
for a band-aid
a sip you want a sip of soda sometimes
you just little parched you don't want
to buy a whole soda
you want to sip yeah wait you go in and
you just get a sip
this is like the anti-costco yeah the
answer to the side classical yeah yeah
yeah you got a sip of soda you get a sip
and then you put it backwards
i wipe it off and i'll put the cap back
on it oh my god
were you talking to gordon ramsay about
trying to mix up different foods come up
with some new dishes
of course he's a connoisseur of fine
food i said man
how about a leguiny dish with sliced
slim jim inside of it
you be surprised slim jim so this sliced
slim jim
and people who love slim jims they will
immediately know what that is
you put that in a dish puddle on the
table you cut them real tiny they'll eat
they eat the linguine and they'll taste
a little bit of slim jim they'll say hmm
is this slim jim now look none of these
things are copyrighted so please don't
steal my stuff conan what are you
talking about
do you have ideas for new shows of ideas
everyone's calling me you gotta be
prepared when people call you
for ideas and you gotta have a lot of
ideas in your head i got one call let's
not make this about me
it's a late night show it comes on even
later than your show lately
later than this show come on my show and
they ask me questions
see like tom hanks comes on there he's
been interviewed a thousand times but
this time he comes on the show and he
asks me questions see
yes i like that idea who wants to see
tom hanks answer another question you've
already heard him
tom hanks asked any other questions yeah
plenty of good ideas
when game of thrones went away there was
a void
left in hbo yeah i said why don't we do
a medieval season a medieval curb your
enthusiasm why not that's hilarious
that's great
yeah i would have wanted i said i want
to be a dragon because i love dragons
i'll be a perfect dragon man a dragon
that talks [ __ ]
and blows fire
you can't just do this after any idea
do you think if colombo came back that i
would be a perfect colombo
yeah i could see that man come on come
on man
come over had that little delivery he
come he come over to see you
and he's like yeah yeah okay uh i see i
get it i get it i get it i get it
and he always turns away he walks away
one more thing when he says one more
thing when he says one more thing
that's your ass drop the cold and put
bro i'll be bro
bro lumbo pro lumber see bro
bro lumbo yeah rhymes
is perfect bro lumbo come on i still you
know
you know i'm a man of fashion i love a
good trench coat i love a good trench
coat
put a little twist coat on come on i'm
still kind of upset that pooty tang
never got it's just dude you know and
putty tang came out in what 95
yeah man we got we got sapped it man we
could we could have been up there we got
sapped it man
but you know what i talked to chris rock
one day i ran into him i said man you
should put out
uh another pooty tank but i told him i
said do not
do pooty tank two right you do pooty
tang three
you skip over two and make people think
they ask miss number two
see you have so many
pretty good ideas i'm a marketing genius